si vous habitez à montargis ce nom ne
vous a pas échappé
la rue gudin la caserne gudin et même un
buste à l'effigié de guide un à l'entrée
du musée girodet bref ce général ami
d'enfance de napoléon est partout et
pourtant peu de montargois le
connaissent c'est évident ça vous parle
pas du tout suite la générale sous
napoléon
[__] c'est pas les poils ou je sais
pas quoi non oui ça me dit quelque chose
après si une personne bah je savais que
de nom vous savez que c'est d'être
quelqu'un qui a compté à montargis
automobile rapporte en tout cas sur le
moteur du coi charles etienne gudin né
ici en 1768 des analyses adn viennent de
confirmer l'identité de ceux
divisionnaire de lempire fauché par un
boulet de canon lors de la campagne
russe
sa dépouille repose et jusqu alors sous
les terres de smolensk
depuis plus de 200 ans c'était un des
grands généraux de lempire compagnon de
napoléon à l'école de brienne donc ils
se sont connus enfants il avait un angle
différent c'est un an plus jeune le plus
vieux par donc que napoléon 1er
donc effectivement il a fait une
carrière extrêmement brillante
général de division quand il est mort et
quinze jours avant sa mort on dit que
l'empereur durée promis le bâton de
maréchal
à la demande des descendants de goût
d'un le corps du général pourra bientôt
être rapatriés en france où il sera peut
être inhumé aux invalides